>> THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS
WILL NOW COME TO ORDER.
AND UNBELIEVABLY, WE I THINK WE
HAVE A QUORUM.
PLEASE TAKE THE ROLL.
>> CABALLERO.
HERE.
JONES.
ASHBY.
HERE.
BECKER.
BRADFORD.
CIERTO.
HERE.
WAHAB.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
WE ARE HOLDING OUR HEARING TODAY
IN
ROOM 113 OF THE STATE CAPITOL.
AND I'M REALLY GLAD TO SEE SO
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS HERE.
SO WE'LL PROBABLY HAVE OTHERS,
UM, THAT WILL JOIN US.
PRESENTLY, WE HAVE EIGHT
MEASURES ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
THESE ARE ALL ITEMS THAT HAVE
TIME SENSITIVITY.
SO WE WILL BE ENTERTAINING DO
PASS
MOTIONS ON THESE MEASURES.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS
LET
US KNOW THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE
FILES ON ANY OF THE MEASURES
THAT
ARE UP FOR A HEARING TODAY.
BEFORE WE BEGIN, I WANT TO
REMIND
ANY WITNESSES TO LIMIT
THEIR TESTIMONY TO THE FISCAL
ASPECTS OF THE BILL.
PLEASE REFRAIN FROM LENGTHY
POLICY DISCUSSIONS
AND REPEATING PRIOR TESTIMONY
IN YOUR COMMENTS.
SO WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM,
SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
THE BUSINESS OF THE DAY.
I'D LIKE TO, UM, START WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB 628 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WILSON.
WELCOME.
PLEASE TELL US ABOUT YOUR BILL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
>> THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
WE DO HAVE TWO BILLS BEFORE YOU
TODAY AND I KNOW ONE
IS LATER AND WE HAD GOT
PERMISSION TO DO IT EARLIER.
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO START WITH
THAT ONE FIRST?
SO IT MAKES SENSE.
UM, IF YOU COULD START WITH
AB 628,
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
OKAY, WE'LL DO ALL RIGHT.
MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS, UM, I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB 628.
THIS IS A COMPANION BILL TO
ACA EIGHT, A MEASURE THAT,
IF PASSED BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
APPROVED BY VOTERS,
WOULD REMOVE THE EXCEPTION IN
OUR STATE
CONSTITUTION THAT CURRENTLY
ALLOWS FOR
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE CONTINGENT
UPON
THE PASSAGE AND APPROVAL OF ACA
EIGHT.
AB 628 REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION,
ALSO KNOWN AS CDCR, TO CREATE
A VOLUNTARY WORK PROGRAM.
FURTHER, IT CLARIFIES THAT CDCR
AND LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
SET COMPENSATION FOR
INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS IN STATE PRISON
FACILITIES
AND LOCAL JAILS, RESPECTIVELY.
IF ACA EIGHT IS APPROVED BY THE
VOTERS,
IT WILL END THE PRACTICE OF
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE,
WHICH IS A RULE THAT HAVE
ALLOWED CALIFORNIA
STATE PRISON TO USE FORCED
LABOR BY REMOVING THE LONG
STANDING EXCEPTION TO
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE FOR
PUNISHMENT OF A CRIME,
AND BY EXPLICITLY PROHIBITING
SLAVERY
AND INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE.
IT WOULD FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE
THE NATURE OF
WORK WITHIN OUR STATE'S CARCERAL
SYSTEM.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN OUR STATE
HISTORY,
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE THAT
WORK ASSIGNMENTS
FOR INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
IS VOLUNTARY,
AND THAT THEY WOULD NOT BE
SUBJECT TO DISCIPLINE
FOR REFUSING A WORK ASSIGNMENT,
ALLOWING FOR GREATER
PARTICIPATION
IN REHABILITATIVE SERVICES,
AND HELPING TO RESTORE DIGNITY
AND BODILY
AUTONOMY TO INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS.
INCARCERATED PEOPLE HAVE LONG
FACED CRUEL
TREATMENT FOR ANY WORK ABSENCES.
THIS INCLUDES SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT,
DENIAL OF PHONE CALLS AND FAMILY
VISITS,
AND LIMITING PARTICIPATION IN
REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS AND DISCIPLINARY
WRITE UPS THAT RESULT IN LONGER
PRISON TERMS.
SUCH PUNISHMENTS OR THREATS OF
SUCH PUNISHMENTS
ARE OFTEN UM, EXCUSE ME,
ARE OFTEN ISSUED EVEN WHEN
ABSENCES ARE DUE TO
ILLNESSES OR INJURIES SUSTAINED
THROUGH WORK.
THE CURRENT PRACTICE OF FORCED
LABOR DOES NOT PREPARE
INCARCERATED PEOPLE FOR SUCCESS
UPON REENTRY,
AND OFTEN PREVENTS PARTICIPATION
IN REHABILITATIVE SERVICES.
THIS BILL CLARIFIES
IMPLEMENTATION OF ACA
EIGHT AND CURRENTLY HAS NO
OPPOSITION.
VERY GOOD.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD
LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL?
IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
AS I INDICATED, THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IS NOT HERE TODAY.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS.
OR A MOTION.
I'LL MOVE.
THERE IS A MOTION.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CONCLUDE?
THANK YOU.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I
VOTE.
VERY GOOD.
PLEASE TAKE THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
CABALLERO.
AYE.
JONES.
ASHBY.
ASHBY I.
BECKER.
I.
BRADFORD.
CIERTO.
WAHAB.
ZERO 3 TO 0.
WE WILL HOLD THAT OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ACA, A ACA EIGHT.
SAY THAT TEN TIMES.
THANK YOU.
UM, MADAM CHAIR, SENATORS,
I'M PLEASED TO SPEAK TO YOU
REGARDING, UH,
ONE OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS REPARATIONS PRIORITY
MEASURES.
THIS IS A SIMPLY CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT EIGHT,
ALSO KNOWN AS ACA EIGHT THE END
SLAVERY IN CALIFORNIA ACT.
UM, FIRST, WE ARE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
UM, THIS MEASURE WOULD ALLOW
CALIFORNIANS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE TO AMEND
ARTICLE ONE,
SECTION SIX OF THE STATE
CONSTITUTION
TO PROHIBIT SLAVERY
AND INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE,
WITHOUT EXCEPTION.
TODAY'S SLAVERY TAKES ON A
MODERN
FORM OF INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE,
INCLUDING FORCED LABOR IN
PRISONS.
SLAVERY IS WRONG IN ALL FORMS,
AND CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE CLEAR
IN DENOUNCING
THAT IN THE CONSTITUTION.
UM, AS A REMINDER,
CALIFORNIA IS ONLY AMONG 16
STATES
WITH AN EXCEPTION CLAUSE FOR
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE.
AND IT STATES CONSTITUTION,
WHICH INCLUDES ALABAMA,
OREGON, TENNESSEE, VERMONT.
ALL OF THEM REMOVED THEIR
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE
LANGUAGE FROM THEIR
CONSTITUTION.
THESE PUNISHMENTS AND THREATS
OF PUNISHMENTS,
AS WAS NOTED IN REGARD TO AB
628,
ARE OFTEN ISSUED EVEN WHEN
ABSENCES ARE DUE
TO ILLNESS OR INJURIES OF
SUSTAINED WORK.
THAT IS NOT DIGNITY, AND THIS
IS ABOUT HUMAN DIGNITY,
INCARCERATION, PEOPLE.
UM, RELATIONSHIP TO WORK SHOULD
NOT BE ONE
OF EXPLOITATION AND LITTLE TO
NO AGENCY.
THIS BILL ALSO ENJOYS NO
OPPOSITION
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE.
SO YOU HAVE A SCRAMBLING UP HERE
BECAUSE I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE ANY AMENDMENTS
AT THIS TIME.
OKAY.
I'M SORRY.
I THOUGHT WE TOOK AMENDMENTS IN
THIS COMMITTEE,
BUT MAYBE THEY WERE 20TH.
>> IT WAS.
AMENDED.
OKAY, THAT THEN THAT WOULD BE
MY APOLOGIES.
I DIDN'T.
MEAN TO.
THAT'S OKAY.
THEY IT LOOKS LIKE THE POINTS
THAT
ARE HAVE ALREADY BEEN TAKEN.
OKAY, GREAT.
ALL RIGHT.
I KNOW WE WERE DOING LOTS OF
LOTS
OF AMENDS AT THE LAST MINUTE.
I DO KNOW THAT TOO.
AND I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE WEREN'T OKAY.
WE WERE ALL ON THE SAME PAGE.
YEP.
AND I GOT THE CLEAR FROM MY
STAFF
THAT THAT WAS CORRECT.
GREAT.
OKAY.
VERY GOOD.
SO, UM, IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
ACA?
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CARMEN NICOLE
COX ON
BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WILSON.
UM, WE ARE PROUD CO-SPONSORS AND
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH.
>> CLIFTON WILSON ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
HEY.
TONY AGUILAR HERE ON BEHALF OF
LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN.
ALL OF US ARE NONE.
A PROUD CO SPONSOR IN SUPPORT
OF ACA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT?
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION?
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION?
SEEING NONE AGAIN.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
NOT HERE,
SO WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS,
QUESTIONS, CONCERNS OR A MOTION.
THERE IS A MOTION, SENATOR
BECKER.
YOU MAY CONCLUDE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
WE'RE GOOD.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
CABALLERO A CABALLERO I.
JONES.
ASHBY.
ASHBY I.
BECKER.
BECKER I.
BRADFORD.
CIERTO.
WAHAB 3 TO 0.
THAT BILL HAS THAT AC HAS THREE
VOTES.
WE'LL PUT IT ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE PROMPTLY.
NEXT WE'LL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE,
WHICH IS UH, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLANCA RUBIO AB 1935.
>> THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND SENATORS RECENTLY SIGNED
AND RATIFIED TRIBAL STATE
GAMING COMPACTS AND SECRETARIAL
PROCEDURES HAVE
CHANGED THE DYNAMICS OF FUTURE
PAYMENTS INTO
THE INDIAN INDIAN GAMING SPECIAL
DISTRIBUTION FUND.
AB 1935 WOULD CODIFY A RECENT
AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE ADMINISTRATION
AND CALIFORNIA'S FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED GAMING TRIBES
ON HOW TO DEAL WITH THE
EXCESSIVE
SURPLUS IN THE FUND,
CURRENTLY EXCEEDING $160 MILLION
IN NON-GENERAL FUND MONIES.
THIS BILL TAKES INTO ACCOUNT
THE INTERESTS
OF THE RESPECTIVE PARTIES,
AS WELL AS THE FUTURE SOLVENCY
OF THE FUND,
WHILE ALLOWING FOR OVER $80
MILLION
IN SURPLUS TO BE SUSPENDED
AND REFUNDED BACK TO THOSE
TRIBES
THAT PAID INTO THE FUND.
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
I VOTE.
VERY GOOD.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF 1935?
>> GOOD MORNING OR GOOD
AFTERNOON,
CHAIRWOMAN CABALLERO AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
MY NAME IS SUSAN JENSEN.
I HAVE THE HONOR OF SERVING AS
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CIENEGA,
WHICH REPRESENTS 52 TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS WHO
ARE UNANIMOUSLY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
UM, I WON'T GO ON BECAUSE THE
CHAIRWOMAN
DID A GREAT JOB OF COMPROMISING.
BUT BASICALLY, THIS BILL
REFLECTS
A FAIR AND EQUITABLE
COMPROMISE BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR
AND TRIBES,
WHICH KEEPS THE SDF SOLVENT
AND STILL
ALLOWS FOR OVER 80 MILLION
IN SURPLUS FUNDS TO BE SUSPENDED
AND REFUNDED BACK TO THE TRIBE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
SCOTT.
GOVERNOR, ON BEHALF OF THE
MORONGO BAND
OF MISSION INDIANS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN
LATIMER,
ON BEHALF OF THE SOBOBA BAND OF
LUISENO INDIANS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT?
IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
SEEING NONE WILL BRING THE THE
AGAIN.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
NOT HERE.
WE'LL BRING THE ISSUE BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE.
ANY COMMENTS, QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS?
THERE IS A MOTION.
SENATOR ASHBY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT.
THANK YOU.
NICE AND SHORT.
APPRECIATE THAT.
UM.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
CABALLERO A CABALLERO I.
JONES.
ASHBY.
ASHBY I.
BECKER.
BECKER I.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CIERTO WAHAB.
AS FOR THE CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
ZERO.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU.
>> LET'S SEE.
WE'LL MOVE ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA,
YOUR NEXT IN LINE.
AB 2288.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM
CHAIR.
AB 2288 WOULD MAKE SEVERAL
REFORMS
THAT IMPROVE ITS EFFECTIVENESS
AS A VITAL TOOL TO TOOL TO
ENFORCE WORKERS RIGHTS,
PROMOTE MAKING WORKERS WHOLE,
AND INCENTIVISE EMPLOYER
COMPLIANCE.
THIS BILL IS A PRODUCT OF
LENGTHY STAKEHOLDER
NEGOTIATIONS TO REFORM
PAGA IN A WAY THAT WOULD HELP
REDUCE
PROLONGED LITIGATION AND,
MOST IMPORTANTLY, IMPROVE THE
OUTCOMES
FOR BOTH WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS.
AB 2288, ALONGSIDE ITS COMPANION
BILL,
SB 92 BY SENATOR UMBERG,
PRESERVES PAGA AS A UNIQUE TOOL
FOR ENFORCEMENT
THAT WILL BENEFIT THE STATE
TWOFOLD,
FIRST, AS A SUPPLEMENT TO THE
STATE'S
LABOR ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS,
GIVEN THE LIMITED PUBLIC
RESOURCES, AND SECOND,
AS A RECIPIENT OF THE 65% AND
RECOVERED PAGA,
PENALTIES THAT WERE REQUIRED
WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO BE PAID TO THE
STATE.
I'M HAPPY STAKEHOLDERS ARE ABLE
TO REACH AN AGREEABLE OUTCOME,
AND BY PASSING AB 2288,
THIS ALLOWS US TO AVOID A BALLOT
MEASURE DESIGNED TO GUT PAGA.
I'M HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
UM, AND FOR COMMENTS.
UH, BEN GOLOMBEK, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
>> UH, MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
BEN GOLOMBEK,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE, UM,
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO 288
AND OBVIOUSLY
ITS COMPANION BILL AS WELL,
SB 92,
WHICH PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED REFORM
TO
THE PRIVATE ATTORNEYS GENERAL
ACT.
WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR,
SENATOR UMBERG,
UM, THE ADMINISTRATION AND OF
COURSE,
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION,
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS
ISSUE.
UM, YOU KNOW, WE'VE HEARD FOR
MANY
YEARS FROM OUR MEMBER COMPANIES,
BOTH LARGE AND SMALL BUSINESSES,
ABOUT HOW FRIVOLOUS PAGA SUITS
HAVE PLAGUED
THEM AND COST MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
AND WHAT WAS ONCE A WELL
INTENTIONED LAW
HAS UNFORTUNATELY BEEN
MANIPULATED,
ENRICHING ATTORNEYS AT THE
EXPENSE OF WORKERS,
SMALL BUSINESSES AND NONPROFITS
WHO SERVE
THE MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS.
WHAT'S IN THIS BILL AND ITS
COMPANION BILL?
UM, REPRESENT HISTORIC REFORMS
TO ADDRESS EMPLOYERS CONCERNS,
WHILE ALSO ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIA
WORKERS CAN FEEL CONFIDENT THAT
THERE'S A ROBUST LABOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT
AGAINST BAD ACTORS.
WE STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS HISTORIC AND LONG
OVERDUE REFORM AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
VERY GOOD.
THOSE IN SUPPORT.
>> MADAM CHAIR CHRIS MICHELI
ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES AREA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND SHERM
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS, KENT
AND STANHOPE,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
NEW CAR DEALERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> UH, MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
MATTHEW ELLSWORTH,
WESTERN GROWERS,
PROUD TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
THANKS.
THANK YOU.
>> MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, LOUIS
BROWN,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
GROCERS ASSOCIATION,
ASEC, AND A COALITION OF
AGRICULTURAL
ASSOCIATIONS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
DOUG SUBERS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS
AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY
EMPLOYEES UNION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT?
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION?
SEEING NO OPPOSITION.
UH, BRING IT BACK AGAIN.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
NOT HERE.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
UH, FOR COMMENTS, QUESTIONS,
CONCERNS.
THERE IS A MOTION BY SENATOR
BRADFORD.
UM, I JUST I WANT TO MAKE SURE,
UM,
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS.
AND I ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THE CALIFORNIA
NEW CAR DEALERS ASSOCIATION,
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE,
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION,
AND WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION
FOR WORKING
WITH ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS,
MANY OF WHOM TESTIFIED HERE
TODAY
TO IMPLEMENT MEANINGFUL,
MEANINGFUL REFORMS OF PAGA.
THIS IS LONG OVERDUE.
UM, IT IS A GOOD DEAL THAT THAT
WILL
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED RELIEF.
SO THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY THAT
HAD
A HAND IN MAKING THIS POSSIBLE.
UM, I BELIEVE IT'S GOING TO
SAVE, UM,
IT'S GOING TO SAVE THE WORKERS
OR GET
THEM MORE MONEY IN THEIR
POCKETS.
UM, STOP THE BAD ACTORS
AND ALSO BE GOOD FOR THE STATE.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT.
WE'LL ALLOW YOU TO CONCLUDE.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
I ALSO DO WANT TO THANK THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION AS
LONG AS AS WELL AS A NUMBER OF
OTHER GROUPS,
THE NEW CAR DEALERS, CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS, CALIFORNIA,
SIERRA AND SO MANY OTHERS THAT
PLAYED A ROLE IN BEING HERE
TODAY AS WELL AS THE GOVERNOR
AND THE MINISTRATION I THINK
THE GOVERNOR IS URGING REALLY
HELPED
US GET TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY,
ALONG WITH LEADERSHIP IN BOTH
OF OUR HOUSES.
UH, AND EVERYTHING YOU SAID IS
ABSOLUTELY TRUE,
MADAM CHAIR,
I THINK THIS WILL BRING RELIEF
TO A LOT OF BUSINESSES
IN TERMS OF FRIVOLOUS
LITIGATION,
WHILE STILL ALLOWING THE CORE OF
WHAT PAGA IS ABOUT
TO BE ABLE TO BE THERE TO
PROTECT WORKERS.
AND WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
VERY GOOD.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR.
CABALLERO I AUTO I JONES.
ASHBY.
BECKER.
BECKER I.
BRADFORD.
I.
CIERTO.
WAHAB.
WHAT WAS THAT NUMBER FOR?
ZERO.
THE VOTE IS 4 TO 0.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
UM, ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA,
YOU'RE UP NEXT.
BUT, UM.
OKAY, WE'LL GO BACK.
THAT.
THAT'S WHAT I FIGURED.
UM, UH, YOUR NEXT UP, AB 2113.
>> THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND COLLEAGUES, GIVEN THAT THIS
IS
A POLICY COMMITTEE I WON'T DIVE
INTO,
THIS IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE.
I WON'T DIVE INTO THE POLICY.
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT A LOT OF
WORK HAS GONE
INTO THIS BY A LARGE
STAKEHOLDER, UH, GROUP.
UM, WE INTRODUCED THIS BILL
TO ALLOW FOR STAKEHOLDERS
TO CHIME IN TO THE POLICY
PROCESS.
UH, ORIGINALLY, THE GOVERNOR
PUT FORWARD
THE POLICY IN A BUDGET TRAILER
BILL.
I THINK THE OUTCOME OF US
ALLOWING
FOR STAKEHOLDERS TO
ENGAGE IN ON AN ISSUE THAT'S
BEEN DECADES OVERDUE, UH,
ALLOW FOR A BALANCED APPROACH
TO SOLVE
A PROBLEM THAT'S BEEN TAKING
PLACE AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE
REGULATION REFORMS,
UH, MEASURES FOR ACCOUNTABILITY
AND THE RESOURCES
THAT THE AGENCY NEEDS TO DO
THEIR JOB,
UM, ON ALL SPECTRUMS,
RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
VERY GOOD.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
2113?
IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION 2113.
OH, A TWEENER.
OKAY, WE'LL TAKE THAT TOO.
MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, LOUIS BROWN,
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF A
COALITION
OF AGRICULTURAL ORGANIZATIONS,
WESTERN PLANT HEALTH
ASSOCIATION, CROPLIFE AMERICA.
WE WERE ORIGINALLY OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL IN THE EFFORTS
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND MR.
GARCIA.
WE ARE NOW NEUTRAL ON THE BILL.
WE REALIZE A LARGE FISCAL IMPACT
THIS HAS,
BUT HOPEFULLY THE TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES,
THE ADDITIONAL STAFF WILL RESULT
IN SIGNIFICANT
BENEFITS TO THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
UH, GOOD AFTERNOON, MATTHEW
ALLEN
WITH WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION.
I CERTAINLY CAN'T EXPAND ON
WHAT MR.
BROWN SAID.
WE'VE BEEN PLEASED TO TO WORK
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THE AUTHOR AND THE DEPARTMENT
ON THIS BILL,
AND WE ARE A NEUTRAL.
THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE NEUTRAL?
OPPOSED.
SUPPORTIVE.
SEEING NO FURTHER TESTIMONY.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK AGAIN.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
NOT HERE.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE
FOR ANY COMMENTS,
QUESTIONS, CONCERNS OR MOTIONS.
THERE IS A MOTION WILL ALLOW YOU
TO CONCLUDE.
THANK YOU FOR THE ANALYSIS AND
RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
VERY GOOD.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR.
CABALLERO.
AYE, I.
JONES.
ASHBY.
ASHBY I.
BECKER.
I.
BRADFORD.
CIERTO.
WAHAB.
WAHAB I.
CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO 0.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGAR CURRY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND FOR BEING HERE ON TIME.
YOU WERE THE FIRST ONE, I THINK.
>> THE ON TIME CAUCUS.
YES.
AB 2813.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB 2813 SIMPLY FURTHERS THE
STATUTORY ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY MEASURES IN
ACA ONE.
AS YOU KNOW, MY OFFICE HAS
WORKED CLOSELY
WITH THE CHAIR AND HER STAFF
SINCE
LAST YEAR TO STRENGTHEN AND
ENSURE THAT
THERE ARE SUFFICIENT GUARDRAILS,
GUARDRAILS IN AB 2813 FOR LOCAL
TRANSPARENCY,
FISCAL OVERSIGHT AND VOTER
PROTECTION.
MADAM CHAIR, BY GIVING LOCALS
THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK TOGETHER WITH THEIR
COMMUNITIES ON LOCAL PROJECTS
THAT
ARE CRITICAL TO THEIR NEEDS,
THESE BILLS REDUCE PRESSURE ON
THE STATE TO FUND SOLUTIONS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS URGENT HOUSING
AND INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
VERY GOOD.
WE HAVE SOME AMENDMENTS NOTED.
TO MAKE SURE.
UH, JUST TO MAKE SURE YOU'RE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDS.
YEAH.
I DIDN'T HAVE MY NOTES.
OKAY.
VERY GOOD.
UM.
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, AND
SENATORS DOUG SUBERS,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR KEITH
DUNN,
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL AND SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT?
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO OPPOSITION AGAIN,
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
NOT HERE,
SO WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS,
QUESTION CONCERNS OR A MOTION.
THERE YOU GO.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED.
OH, I ALWAYS FORGET THE CLOTHES.
I'M MOVING TOO FAST.
FOR YOUR.
EYE.
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS DO PASSES AMENDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
CABALLERO A CABALLERO I JONES.
ASHBY.
ASHBY I.
BECKER.
BECKER I.
BRADFORD.
I CIERTO.
WAHAB.
WAHAB I.
CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO 0.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND YOUR SECOND BILL IS ACA TEN.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS ONCE AGAIN.
ACA TEN WILL REMOVE THE SPECIAL
TAX PROVISIONS IN ACA ONE.
BONDING WILL BE THE ONLY NEW
FISCAL
TOOL AVAILABLE FOR TO LOCALS
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
MADAM CHAIR, BY GIVING LOCALS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK TOGETHER
WITH
THE THEIR COMMUNITIES ON LOCAL
PROJECTS
THAT ARE CRITICAL TO THEIR
NEEDS,
THESE BILLS REDUCE PRESSURE ON
THE STATE TO FUND SOLUTIONS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS URGENT HOUSING
AND INFRASTRUCTURE PROBLEMS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
VERY GOOD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, AND
SENATORS DOUG SUBERS,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
KEITH DUNN, ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SCOTT.
GOVERNOR, ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSTRUCTION
EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT?
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION?
SEEING NO OPPOSITION AGAIN,
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
NOT HERE,
SO WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS,
CONCERNS OR MOTION.
MOTION BY SENATOR ASHBY WILL
ALLOW YOU TO CONCLUDE.
YEAH, WELL, IT WAS A
VENTRILOQUIST
KIND OF SITUATION.
SHE WAS JUST VERY QUIET.
SHE SHE.
YEAH.
YOU CAN TELL WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH TO DO.
UM.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
VERY GOOD.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
CABALLERO A A JONES.
ASHBY.
ASHBY I.
BECKER I.
BECKER I BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CIERTO WAHAB WAHHAB.
I THANK YOU SENATOR.
THE VOTE IS 5 TO 0.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY.
AB 2927.
WELCOME.
>> ARE YOU GOING REALLY FAST?
I FEEL LIKE I SHOULD TALK FAST,
TOO.
NO, IT'S ALL GOOD.
YEAH.
SO THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT THIS MEASURE
RELATED TO FINANCIAL
LITERACY FOR OUR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
UM, YOU KNOW, I HAVE HIGH
SCHOOLERS AT HOME,
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT WHEN
THEY LEARN
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A DEBIT
CARD AND A CREDIT CARD,
THEY'RE LIKE, HUH?
INTERESTING.
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOUNG PEOPLE GO
OFF TO COLLEGE, UM, THEY.
BEFORE THEY FIND THE BOOKSTORE
AND THE LIBRARY,
THEY'LL PASS A TABLE SIGNING UP
FOR MULTIPLE CREDIT CARDS.
UM, YOU KNOW, WHEN THEY GET
STUDENT LOAN PACKAGES,
WHEN THEY'RE 18, YOU ASK THEM,
YOU KNOW,
WHEN THEY GET FINANCIAL AID
PACKAGES
FROM COLLEGES, YOU ASK THEM,
ARE YOU GETTING LOANS OR ARE YOU
GETTING GRANTS?
LIKE, I DON'T KNOW, I'M GETTING
FINANCIAL AID.
WELL, THOSE DETAILS MATTER.
AND SO 17 STATES HAVE ALREADY
HAVE THIS
THROUGHOUT OUR NATION AS FAR AS,
UH, GRADUATION REQUIREMENT FOR
FINANCIAL LITERACY.
AS YOU KNOW, THERE IS A
POTENTIAL
BALLOT MEASURE ON THIS.
WE'VE WORKED TO NEGOTIATE WITH
ALL
PARTIES TO REMOVE OPPOSITION
TO DRAMATICALLY LOWER THE
IMPLEMENTATION COST.
AND WITH THAT, WE THINK WE HAVE
A MEASURE THAT DOES THIS TODAY.
UM, YOU KNOW, WE LISTENED TO
SOME OF THE CONCERNS FROM
LAST YEAR AND HAVE MULTIPLE
YEARS OF IMPLEMENTATION,
AS WELL AS FINDING WAYS HOW
WE CAN
MAKE IT EASIER FOR COUNSELORS
AND STUDENTS TO FIT THIS IN
THEIR COURSE REQUIREMENTS
BY ALLOWING THIS FINANCIAL
PERSONAL
FINANCE COURSE TO BE
SUBSTITUTED FOR THE ECONOMICS
COURSE UPON GRADUATION.
UH, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
UH, I HAVE ONE WITNESS HERE
TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
VERY GOOD.
>> MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS JOE
LANG,
REPRESENTING THE NEXT GENERATION
FINANCIAL.
LITERACY FOUNDATION, A
NON-PROFIT
FOUNDATION ESTABLISHED TO HELP
PROMOTE FINANCIAL LITERACY
COURSES
IN STATES AROUND THE COUNTRY.
AND I THINK OUR AUTHOR DESCRIBED
PROPERLY,
WORKED WITH A LOT OF
STAKEHOLDERS.
I THINK THIS BILL IS A VERY GOOD
PRODUCT,
AND WE DID DO OUR BEST TO
TRY AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
FISCAL
IMPACT WAS AS LITTLE AS
POSSIBLE,
WHILE STILL ACHIEVING THE GOAL
OF HELPING TO EDUCATE
YOUNG STUDENTS ABOUT THEIR
FINANCIAL FUTURE.
SO WITH THAT, THANK YOU AND WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
>> MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS, BOB
GIROUX,
ON BEHALF OF THE INTUIT
CORPORATION,
WE MANUFACTURE TURBOTAX, QUICKEN
AND QUICKBOOKS.
IT'S OUR MISSION TO ENSURE THAT
THE PUBLIC UNDERSTANDS
AND IS FINANCIALLY LITERATE AND
WE SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT?
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
THE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
NOT HERE.
UH, BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR WAHAB MOVES THE BILL.
ANY COMMENTS?
CONCERNS YOU MAY CONCLUDE.
THANK YOU.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
VERY GOOD.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
CABALLERO A A JONES 2927.
YES.
JONES, I.
ASHBY.
ASHBY I.
BECKER.
BECKER I.
BRADFORD.
I.
CIERTO.
WAHAB.
WAHAB I.
CURRENT VOTE IS 6 TO 0.
WE'LL PUT IT ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
SO WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A BRIEF
RECESS SO
WE CAN GET THE ABSENT MEMBERS
HERE.
SO WE CAN GO THROUGH THE ROLL
CALL ONCE.
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE
WILL BE BACK IN SESSION,
AND WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH
THE AGENDA ITEMS ONE FINAL TIME.
WE'LL START WITH ITEM NUMBER
1AB6
28 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR.
JONES.
>> UM.
BRADFORD.
ITEM ONE.
UH UH OH.
BRADFORD.
I CIERTO.
NO.
CIERTO.
WAHAB.
WAHAB I 5.
TO 1 THAT, UH.
BILL IS OUT.
5 TO 1.
MOVING ON TO AC EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON.
THE MOTIONS DO PASS.
JONES.
>> UH.
NOT BRADFORD.
BRADFORD.
I CIERTO.
CIERTO.
NO.
WAHAB.
WAHAB I THAT BILL IS OUT 5 TO
1 AB 1935
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO.
THAT THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS.
JONES.
I CIERTO.
CIERTO.
I WAHAB.
WAHAB I THAT BILL IS OUT 7 TO 0.
MOVING ON TO AB 2113 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA.
THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS.
JONES.
NO.
CIERTO.
THAT BILL IS OUT 5 TO 2.
AB 2288 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA.
THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS.
JONES.
JONES I CIERTO CIERTO I WAHAB.
WAHHAB I 7 TO 0.
THE BILL IS OUT 7 TO 0.
AB 2813 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUILAR
CURRY THAT THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS AS AMENDED.
JONES.
NO.
CIERTO.
THAT BILL IS OUT 5 TO 2.
MOVING ON TO ACA TEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGUILAR CURRY.
THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS.
JONES.
NO.
CIERTO.
THAT BILL IS OUT 5 TO 2.
AB 2927 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY.
THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS CIERTO CIERTO I 7 TO 0.
THAT BILL IS OUT 7 TO 0.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING FOR TODAY.
I'D LIKE TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
PARTICIPATING.
UM, WE HAVE CONCLUDED OUR AGENDA
AND THE SENATE MEETING.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATION IS ADJOURNED.